le temps d'une visite à l'aéroport ils
se sont retrouvés sans savoir dans la
mire des espions canadiens
des dizaines de milliers de voyageurs
leur téléphone leur tablette détectée
par le réseau sans fil d'un aéroport non
identifié leurs empreintes digitales
électroniques envoyés au centre de la
sécurité des télécommunications qui les
a suivis à la trace pendant des jours
comme si votre téléphone dit ce
spécialiste
dorothée était devenu un bracelet
électronique
l'opération est expliqué dans cette note
du centre de la sécurité des
télécommunications daté du 10 mai 2012
le document top secret et obtenu par la
cbi ci est l'un de ceux coulé par l'ex
consultant de la cia edward snowdon l'
agence d'espionnage canadienne voulait
voir s'ils pouvaient suivre quelqu'un
grâce à son téléphone en surveillant ses
apparitions sur internet à l'aéroport à
l'hôtel dans les cafés chaque fois en
fait qu'ils passaient près d'une borne
de services sans fil
l'expérience est un succès conclut le
document appelé à transformer le monde
de l'espionnage
la commissaire à la vie privée de
l'ontario est renversé c'est incroyable
dit elle que le centre puisse mener ce
genre d'opération c'est que la loi
interdit au centre d'espionner au canada
où des canadiens comme le soulignait
récemment son grand patron canap target
par courriel le centre de la sécurité
des télécommunications affirme qu'il
respecte la loi que la collecte de
données n'est pas illégal que les gens
ne sont pas suivis que les conversations
ne sont pas écoutés n'empêche ce
spécialiste a de sérieux doutes sur la
légalité de l'opération et en jouant à
fond et se demande surtout comment l'
agence d'espionnage a pu avoir accès à
tous ces réseaux normalement qualifié de
sécuritaire